في هذا المبنى في الطابق السادس عثر على
وثائق التقريبا 10 صنفت بانها وثائق سريه
تابعه للرئيس بيضين عندما كان يشغل منصب
نائبا رئيس طبعا هذا سبب احراج كبير لل
البيت الابيض لانه اتهم بالزواجيه
المعايير بالمقارنه مما حدث مع الرئيس
ترامب الذي حقق الاف بي اي في الوثائق
التي وجدت في مره لارجو لكن البعض يقول
بانه لا مقارنه اولا البيت الابيض اعرب عن
تعاونه مع طبعا مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي
وقال بانه يريد ان يعيد كل هذه الوثائق
الى الارشيف الوطني وان هذه الوثائق لا
تحمل مثلا اسرار نوويه او غيرها لكن بغض
النظر رئيس مجلس النواب كيف مقاسي قال بان
الامر مقلق للغايه وهذا طبعا سيسبب احراج
كبير للبيت الابيض وقد يؤثر على مستقبل
الرئيس السيسي